lotion finalmente atracó en territorio
europeo después de vagar más de 20 días
en el Mediterráneo el navío con más de
230 migrantes desembarcó en el puerto
militar de tulón al sur de Francia el
país galo nunca antes había permitido
que un barco de rescate que transportaba
migrantes en el Mediterráneo
desembarcara en su costa Pero esta vez
el gobierno centrista de Manuel macron
hizo una excepción luego de que Italia
Le negara el acceso al navío
Nuestro objetivo es comenzar muy
rápidamente todos los procedimientos que
nos permitan pronunciarnos sobre la
situación de estas personas aplicar
todos los procedimientos de reubicación
con los nueve países de la Unión Europea
que se comprometieron anoche y para las
personas que no están destinadas a
permanecer en Francia ni se benefician
de la reubicación en otros países
europeos para organizar su regreso a su
país de origen la decisión italiana de
rechazar la llegada de los migrantes fue
calificada de incomprensible por Francia
y dejó fracturada las relaciones con
Roma la nueva primera mini italiana
Georgia meloni reaccionó sobre las
tensiones con París
a las reacciones
agresiva me llamó la atención la
reacción agresiva del gobierno francés
que desde mi punto de vista es
incomprensible e injustificada Qué es
exactamente lo que les enoja tanto el
hecho de que Italia debe ser el único
Puerto posible de desembarco para los
migrantes del Mediterráneo porque eso no
está escrito en ningún acuerdo Aunque
oficialmente no están en suelo francés
sino en una zona internacional los más
de 170 adultos y los 57 menores deberán
pasar por un control sanitario
entrevistas con la inteligencia francesa
y procedimientos de la oficina encargada
de los refugiados de Francia para
evaluar quién cumple con Los criterios
necesarios para pedir asilo Francia
acogerá un tercio de las personas
Alemania otro tercio mientras que otros
ocho países del bloque al resto de los
migrantes